This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantam. There's a popular inspirational quote, often attributed to Mahatma Gandhi, that's made its way onto t-shirts, mugs, and posters. Be the change you wish to see in the world. It's a noble idea, but the truth is, few of us follow it. Life gets in the way. We compromise. We delay. We put aside our idealism as youthful naivete.
这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是香卡·维丹塔姆。有一句广受欢迎的励志名言，通常被认为是圣雄甘地说的，它出现在T恤、马克杯和海报上。“欲变世界，先变其身。”这是一个高尚的想法，但事实是，我们中很少有人能做到。生活总会带来阻碍。我们妥协。我们拖延。我们将我们的理想主义贬斥为年轻时的天真。
But what would happen if we didn't do this? If we stood fully by our principles. Plenty of people have tried. Julia Butterfly Hill spent two years in a redwood tree she named Luna to keep it safe from lagers. There's some people, I'm just a dirty tree hug and hippie, but I just, I can't imagine being able to take a chain, so there's something like this. And then there was Levoi Finicum, an Arizona rancher who defied the federal government and
但是如果我们不这样做会发生什么呢？如果我们完全坚守我们的原则。很多人都尝试过。茱莉亚·巴特弗莱·希尔在一棵被她命名为“露娜”的红杉树上生活了两年，以保护它免受伐木工的伤害。有些人会觉得，我只是一个激进的环保主义者和嬉皮士，但我只是——我无法想象能够拿着电锯去砍伐这样的东西。然后是莱沃伊·菲尼库姆，一个亚利桑那州的牧场主，他公然反抗联邦政府，
kept grazing his cattle on federal land After he was asked to remove them. This fight I'm making America. It's not about cows and it's not about grass It's about the freedom of our land This grazing right is my personal property right I own it Julia butterfly hails saved the tree after she and her supporters negotiated an agreement with the timber company. Levoifenikim was killed by Oregon State police during a standoff on a federal wildlife refuge. Both said they had no choice but to take the drastic actions. It was a matter of principle.
坚持在联邦土地上放牧，尽管他被要求将牛群迁走。我为之奋斗的美国。这与牛无关，也与草无关，这是关于我们土地的自由，这种放牧权是我的个人财产权，我拥有它。在茱莉亚·巴特弗莱·希尔与伐木公司达成协议后，她和支持者们拯救了这棵树。莱沃伊·菲尼库姆在联邦野生动物庇护所与警方对峙期间，被俄勒冈州州警击毙。两人都表示，他们别无选择，只能采取激进的行动。这是原则问题。
But the truth is, in daily life, we often veer away from people like this. They can be exhausting, grating. They stick to their principles no matter how small the benefit or how great the cost. This week we have the story of a couple with ideals that run just as deep. A couple who wanted to live their own lives based on what they believed without compromise and without regard for the consequences. It was far harder than they could have ever imagined. There was a lot of loss involved.
但事实是，在日常生活中，我们经常避开这样的人。他们可能会让人筋疲力尽，令人厌烦。他们坚守原则，无论好处有多小，代价有多大。本周，我们讲述一对有着同样坚定理想的夫妇的故事。一对希望完全根据自己的信仰生活，不妥协、不计后果的夫妇。这比他们想象的要艰难得多。其中包含着许多失去。
What it takes to walk the walk, this week on Hidden Brain. Our story begins with two young people who decided to start their adult lives with service to the nation. In 1994, President Bill Clinton created AmeriCorps. It's a national community service program modeled after the Peace Corps. In a swearing and ceremony on the front steps of the White House, Clinton told the first class of volunteers that they were giving new life to the values that bind Americans. But when it is all said and done, it comes down to three simple questions. What is right?
践行信念需要付出什么，本周《隐藏的大脑》。我们的故事始于两个决定以服务国家开启成年生活的年轻人。1994年，比尔·克林顿总统创立了“美国国民服务队”。这是一个仿效和平队的国家社区服务项目。在白宫台阶上的宣誓就职仪式上，克林顿对第一批志愿者说，他们正在为维系美国人的价值观注入新的生命。但归根结底，它归结为三个简单的问题。什么是对的？
What is wrong? And what are we going to do about it? Today you are doing what is right? Turning your words into deeds turning your words into deeds. Turning words into deeds. That was the idealistic goal made clear by the oath of service. Let me ask all the AmeriCorps volunteers here to raise your hand and repeat after me. I will get things done for America.
什么是错的？我们又该为此做些什么？今天你们在做正确的事？把你们的话语变成行动，把你们的话语变成行动。把话语变成行动。这是服务誓言所阐明的理想主义目标。请允许我请这里的全体美国国民服务队志愿者举起手来跟我重复。我将为美国办成实事。
I will get things done for America. To make our people safer, smarter, and healthier. In exchange for a small living stipend and help with educational costs, AmeriCorps volunteer spend about a year in community service. They tutor disadvantaged kids, build homes in poor neighborhoods, provide maintenance in the national parks. Faced with adversity, I will persevere. Faced with adversity, I will persevere. I am an AmeriCorps member.
我将为美国办成实事。让我们的同胞更安全、更聪明、更健康。作为获得少量生活津贴和教育费用补助的回报，美国国民服务队志愿者会进行大约一年的社区服务。他们辅导弱势儿童，在贫困社区建造房屋，在国家公园提供维护。面对逆境，我将坚持不懈。面对逆境，我将坚持不懈。我是一名美国国民服务队队员。
I am AmeriCorps member. And I am going to get things done. And I am going to get things done. Yes. In 1995, Jessica Karns took the AmeriCorps O. So did Royce James. Jessica had recently graduated from high school in New York. Royce was a Washington DC native.
我是一名美国国民服务队队员。我将办成实事。我将办成实事。是的。1995年，杰西卡·卡恩斯参加了美国国民服务队。罗伊斯·詹姆斯也是。杰西卡刚刚从纽约的高中毕业。罗伊斯是华盛顿特区本地人。
They were both assigned to the AmeriCorps campus in Denver. The volunteers were housed together in the barracks of an old Air Force Base. Jessica says when she first met Royce, she just really liked him. Royce was... Royce is a very handsome man. And a very loving and charismatic person. He was a leader in our campus community, getting all of the campus involved in extra service projects beyond what we needed to do. Like teaching music to kids at the Boys and Girls Club,
他们都被分配到了丹佛的美国国民服务队营地。志愿者们一起住在旧空军基地的营房里。杰西卡说，她第一次见到罗伊斯时，就真的很喜欢他。罗伊斯是……罗伊斯是一个非常帅气的男人。是一个非常慈爱且极具个人魅力的人。他是我们校园社区的领袖，让整个校园都参与到超出我们本职要求的额外服务项目中去。比如在男孩女孩俱乐部教孩子们音乐，
Jessica liked that, the way Royce jumped right in. When they weren't working, the volunteers hung out together. They played a lot of ultimate frisbee. They bonded. Eventually, people began pairing up in the way that people do when they are young and broke and helping the world. For Jessica and Royce, their connection started with a mishap. He hit me in the head with his frisbee. And then grew during an impromptu road trip with friends to Santa Fe. I just remember starting to look at him a little bit. Frisbee. And then grew during an impromptu road trip with friends to Santa Fe.
杰西卡喜欢这一点，喜欢罗伊斯二话不说就投入其中的样子。不工作的时候，志愿者们聚在一起。他们玩很多极限飞盘。他们建立了深厚的感情。最终，人们开始像年轻、穷困且渴望拯救世界的年轻人那样开始配对。对杰西卡和罗伊斯来说，他们的缘分始于一次小意外。他的飞盘砸到了我的头。然后在和朋友去圣达菲的即兴公路旅行中感情加深。我只记得开始有点看着他了。飞盘。然后在和朋友去圣达菲的即兴公路旅行中感情加深。
I just remember starting to look at him a little bit differently. Like, oh, that's a very, very good-looking man. I already knew he was a really good person and a really fun, good friend. So that's probably where we probably fell in love in the land of enchantment in New Mexico. It just happened. It was a definite, I'm looking at you in a different way and understanding you in a different way. I don't know if it was the atmosphere or the weekend or just the clarity of not pushing
我只记得开始有点用不同的眼光看他了。心想，哦，那是一个非常非常帅的男人。我早就知道他是一个真正的好人，也是一个非常有趣的好朋友。所以那可能就是我们在新墨西哥州的魔幻之地上坠入爱河的地方吧。它就那样发生了。那是一种确定的、用不同的眼光看着你并以不同的方式理解你的感觉。我不知道是因为那里的气氛、那个周末，还是仅仅因为不再强求的那种清明。
so hard. And oftentimes I find that when my heart does the right thing and I was lucky enough to be able to listen and have that reciprocated. Jessica and Royce decided that once their time with the AmeriCorps was over, they go to college at New Mexico State. They moved into an Adobe apartment with a spiral staircase and a classic New Mexico railing in turquoise. They loved it and they loved the university. Jessica was getting a double major in women's studies and sociology and I was doing my music math
而且我经常发现，当我的心做出了正确的事情时，我很幸运能够倾听并得到回应。杰西卡和罗伊斯决定，一旦他们在国民服务队的任期结束，他们就去新墨西哥州立大学上学。他们搬进了一间带螺旋楼梯和经典土耳其玉色栏杆的土坯公寓。他们很喜欢那里，也很喜欢这所大学。杰西卡正在攻读女性研究和社会学的双学位，而我则是在攻读物理学专业的同时辅修音乐和数学。
minors with my physics major. In the clear New Mexico evenings after class they talk about what they were learning and the ideas and questions they were grappling with. They thought a lot about social justice, oppression, fairness. You know, what does it mean to exist and be a feminist? What does it mean to exist and be an activist? What does it mean to exist and be a proponent of rights for indigenous people? So I mean, these were parts of our lives and we just continue to have these types of conversations. Conversations that lots of students have during college when late nights in cheap beer
课后在新墨西哥州晴朗的傍晚，他们会谈论他们正在学习的内容以及他们正在努力解决的想法和问题。他们思考了很多关于社会公正、压迫、公平的问题。你知道，作为一个女性存在意味着什么？作为一个活动家存在意味着什么？作为一个原住民权利的支持者存在意味着什么？所以我的意思是，这些都是我们生活的一部分，我们只是继续进行这些类型的对话。许多大学生在深夜喝着便宜啤酒时进行的那种对话，
produce passionate arguments. The thing about Jessica and Royce is that they didn't see these issues as just debate fodder. This is who they were. Royce, for instance, grew up with family stories of the Civil Rights Movement. In 1960, his uncle, Franklin McCain, was one of four young black college freshmen who sat down at a white son Lee Woolworth lunch counter in Greensboro, North Carolina.
会产生充满激情的争论。杰西卡和罗伊斯的不同之处在于，他们不把这些议题仅仅看作辩论的素材。这就是他们自己。例如，罗伊斯的成长伴随着民权运动的家族故事。1960年，他的叔叔富兰克林·麦凯恩是北卡罗来纳州格林斯伯勒市四位年轻的黑人大学新生之一，他们坐在了一家白人专属的伍尔沃斯午餐柜台前。
Four college freshmen, all Negroes, were refused service at a Greensboro, North Carolina lunch counter, and the civil rights sit-in was born. Over the coming days, the lunch counter protest grew and spread. More than 1,500 Negroes were jailed over a period of several days. Most of them, students from the North Carolina Agricultural and Technical Institute and from Bennett College. Mr. Farmer said the entire Negro population, 40,000, stood ready to go to jail. The protest eventually led to the desegregation of lunch counters across the South, a major victory
四位全都是黑人的大学新生在北卡罗来纳州格林斯伯勒的一家午餐柜台遭到拒绝服务，民权静坐抗议由此诞生。在接下来的几天里，午餐柜台抗议活动不断发展并蔓延。在几天的时间里，有1500多名黑人被捕。他们大多来自北卡罗来纳农业技术学院和贝内特学院的学生。法默先生说，全体黑人居民（4万人）随时准备入狱。抗议活动最终导致南方各地午餐柜台取消了种族隔离，这是民权运动中的一项重大胜利。
in the civil rights movement. Years later, Franklin McCain talked about his role as one of the Greensboro 4 as the young men came to be known. He said he acted because it was time to take a stand. If there is something that you want to do in your heart, you know that it needs to be changed, modified, or turned upside down. Go ahead and do it. Don't follow your head.
多年后，富兰克林·麦凯恩谈到了他作为“格林斯伯勒四人组”（后来人们这样称呼这群年轻人）成员的角色。他说他采取行动是因为是时候表明立场了。如果内心有什么你想做的事，你知道它需要被改变、修正或颠覆。那就去做吧。不要听从你的大脑。
Don't follow your heart. Follow your gut. Roy Simbrase's his uncle's advice. It's one reason he pays such close attention to injustice and inequality. And he feels it in his own life. When he and Jessica sit down to eat at a restaurant today as an interracial couple, they still
不要听从你的心。听从你的直觉。罗伊斯铭记着他叔叔的建议。这也是他如此密切关注不公正和不平等现象的原因之一。他在自己的生活中也能感受到这一点。如今，当他和杰西卡作为一对跨种族伴侣坐在一起在餐馆吃饭时，他们仍然
experience remnants of prejudice from long ago. There's often times where the server will kind of look at both of us and really not know what to do because they don't know. Wait, there's a white woman there and a black man, who do I get the check to you? Jessica and Roy strongly felt that they wanted to live honest, open lives, unencumbered by systems of bias and oppression. The more they talked, the more they were sure it was the right way to live. At school, Jessica came across an idea so powerful she couldn't stop thinking about it.
会经历残留自很久以前的偏见。经常会有服务员看着我们俩，真不知道该怎么办，因为他们不知道。等等，那里有一个白人女性和一个黑人男性，我该把账单给谁？杰西卡和罗伊斯强烈地觉得，他们想要过诚实、公开的生活，不受偏见和压迫系统的阻碍。他们谈论得越多，就越确信这是正确的生存方式。在学校里，杰西卡偶然接触到一个如此强大的想法，以至于她对它念念不忘。
For her undergraduate degree in women's studies, she began a research paper. About gender stratification in pre-K. And that was when I first recognized and started looking at the things that adults project onto children from birth that affects the way that children move through and experience the world. Suddenly Jessica began seeing how gender shapes all kinds of choices. I remember working at the Boys and Girls Club near our college and seeing the children watching how they played and how they were able to play based on what they were wearing and thinking those girls could also be up at the top of that play scape swinging upside down if they weren't wearing sandals and sun dresses. A little earlier Jessica had come to a similar insight about her own life. Like a lot of women, Jessica had always thought she was bad at math. Before starting college, she had to take remedial algebra.
为了完成她的女性研究本科学位，她开始写一篇研究论文。关于学前教育中的性别分层。正是在那个时候，我第一次认识到并开始审视成年人从出生起就投射到儿童身上的事物，这些事物影响着儿童在世界中前行和体验世界的方式。突然间，杰西卡开始看到性别是如何塑造各种选择的。我记得在离我们大学不远的男孩女孩俱乐部工作时，看到孩子们观察他们如何玩耍，以及他们如何根据自己穿的衣服来决定能玩什么，心想如果那些女孩没有穿着凉鞋和太阳裙，她们也可以爬到那个游乐设施的最顶端倒挂着荡秋千。稍早之前，杰西卡对自己的生活也有了类似的感悟。和很多女性一样，杰西卡一直认为自己不擅长数学。在开始上大学之前，她不得不参加补习代数。
She expected to do poorly. One night, as she struggled with the problem, she asked Royce for help. I just remember I was writing a song at the time, with my guitar, and I turned the paper over and said, well, just read it to me like it says, and I worked it out, and then I said, okay, well, let's go through it piece by piece. And she just needed the little confidence boost. That's all it took, some confidence, someone who expected she could do it,
她预计自己会考得很差。一天晚上，当她在一道题上苦苦挣扎时，她向罗伊斯求助。我只记得我当时正在用吉他写一首歌，我把纸翻过来对他说，好吧，你就照着上面写的读给我听，然后我把它解出来了，接着我说，好吧，那我们一块儿一点一点地过一遍。她只是需要一点自信心的提升。仅此而已，需要一些信心，需要一个期望她能做到的人，
who didn't let her off the hook. Jessica began to wonder why, as a child, her teachers hadn't done the same thing, expected that she could be good at math. Looking back, and this is me kind of when I was at this point in college and learning these new things, looking back on that experience of math, the early math, doing a long division problem and thinking maybe the teacher didn't, wasn't surprised that I couldn't solve that problem because I was a girl.
一个不会轻易放过她的人。杰西卡开始纳闷，为什么在她小时候，她的老师没有做同样的事情，去期望她能擅长数学。回想起来，这也就是我在大学这个阶段学习这些新东西的时候，回想起早期学数学的那段经历，做长除法运算时心想，也许老师不……对解不出那道题并不感到惊讶，因为我是个女孩。
Her newly-sohn confidence made a difference in that remedial algebra class. And I got an A, and I was so amazed, and it changed the course of my experience and what I thought that I could even take in college. Jessica added this experience to her mental catalog of biases. Gender, like race, is an accident
她新获得的自信在那门补习代数课上发挥了作用。我得了A，我太惊讶了，它改变了我的经历历程，以及我对自己在大学里甚至能选修什么的看法。杰西卡将这段经历加入了她脑海中的偏见目录。性别和种族一样，是一场出生时的
of birth. So why does it define so much of what we can and cannot do? She and Royce began to mull over gender issues in their evening conversations. They felt they were opening their eyes to rules about how boys and girls are supposed to behave. Rules so ingrained that people don't notice them anymore. These are the things that were just steeped in in the world. I don't think we're encouraged to take a minute and think about how we
偶然。那么，为什么它决定了我们能做什么和不能做什么的那么多方面呢？她和罗伊斯开始在晚上的交谈中琢磨性别问题。他们觉得自己的双眼正在被打开，去发现那些关于男孩和女孩应该如何行为的规则。这些规则如此根深蒂固，以至于人们不再注意到它们。这些事情都是世界所浸染的。我认为我们并不被鼓励花上一分钟去思考我们如何
decide to dress our babies. How we choose the favorite color for our babies depending on what their sex is or when you say that you're expecting and somebody says, what is it? And you don't answer with, well, it's a human. You're expected to answer with a particular, it's a boy or it's a girl. And Jessica believes that label, boy or girl, shapes the whole experience of how the family and the community responds to the pregnancy and the birth and the preparations.
决定给我们的小宝贝穿什么。我们如何根据婴儿的性别来选择他们最喜欢的颜色，或者当你说你怀孕了时，有人会问，是个男孩还是女孩？而你没有回答说，嗯，是一个人类。人们期望你给出一个特定的回答，是个男孩还是个女孩。杰西卡认为，“男孩”或“女孩”这个标签塑造了家庭和社区对怀孕、出生以及各种准备工作做出反应的整个体验。
And so even just sitting with that, oh my goodness, those are actual, those are maybe unconscious choices, but they are actually choices. The young couple weren't planning on becoming parents anytime soon. In fact, after graduating from college, they headed to different cities. Royce was off to New London, Connecticut to office her candidate school for the Coast Guard. Jessica took a job in Washington, D.C. as a statistician with a Census Bureau, thanks to her math success. She also made plans to start graduate school.
因此，甚至只是静静地体会这一点——哦天哪，这些是实际存在的，这些可能是不知不觉的选择，但它们确实是选择。这对年轻夫妇并没有打算很快成为父母。事实上，大学毕业后，他们前往了不同的城市。罗伊斯前往康涅狄格州新伦敦参加海岸警卫队军官候补学校。多亏了数学上的成功，杰西卡在华盛顿特区人口普查局找到了一份统计员的工作。她还计划开始读研究生。
They saw each other when they could. Sometimes she'd go north to him. Sometimes he'd come south to her. It was after one of those visits that Jessica discovered she was pregnant. Royce was back in New London and as a young officer candidate, he didn't have phone privileges. I had to send him a letter, FedEx. I forgot all that, that's right, I got a letter, a FedEx letter that told me that we were pregnant.
他们抽空见面。有时她向北去找他。有时他向南去找她。正是在其中一次探访之后，杰西卡发现自己怀孕了。罗伊斯当时回到了新伦敦，作为一名年轻的军官候补生，他没有电话特权。我必须给他寄一封信，通过联邦快递。我把那事全忘了，没错，我收到了一封信，一封联邦快递的信，告诉我我们怀孕了。
They made new plans. Royce got a land-based assignment with the Coast Guard. Jessica put grad school on hold. They got married. They started preparing for the baby. Jessica wanted to have a pregnancy with minimal medical intervention, with one exception, an ultrasound. And that's how she learned she was
他们做出了新的计划。罗伊斯得到了海岸警卫队的一个岸上岗位。杰西卡把研究生学业暂时搁置。他们结婚了。他们开始为孩子做准备。杰西卡希望进行极少医疗干预的怀孕，但有一个例外——超声波检查。这就是她得知自己怀的是一个
carrying a girl. Suddenly, all those things about gender she'd made a mental note off, they felt very real. I started thinking about how I wanted to shape things a little bit differently from the very beginning. Jessica didn't want her daughter to be lumped into a category. She didn't want the princess. She didn't want the baby in pink. I'd really like to give her a chance to figure out what, what even her favorite color is and figure out who she is as a person and not as an idea about what other people think she should be. What Jessica wanted was to raise her daughter free from gender stereotypes. It's an idea that others have pondered for many decades.
女孩的方式。突然之间，所有她做过心理记录的关于性别的事情，都变得非常真实。我开始思考，我希望从一开始就以稍微不同的方式来塑造事情。杰西卡不希望她的女儿被归入某个类别。她不想要公主。她不想要穿着粉红色的婴儿。我真的很想给她一个机会去弄清楚，甚至她最喜欢的是什么颜色，去弄清楚她作为一个人是谁，而不是作为别人认为她应该成为的那种概念。杰西卡想要的是抚养女儿摆脱性别刻板印象。这个想法其他人已经思考了几十年。
Back in the early 1970s, for instance, the author Lois Gould wrote a fictional account for Ms. magazine about a couple trying to raise a genderless child. The story of X created a sensation. It was eventually turned into a book, and in 2016, an animated short film. Once upon a time, a baby named X was born. This baby was named X because no one could tell whether it was a boy or a girl. Its parents could tell of course, but they couldn't tell anyone else. You see, it was all part of a very important secret scientific experiment and it officially has Project Baby X.
例如，早在20世纪70年代初，作家洛伊丝·古尔德在《女士》杂志上写了一篇科幻小说，讲述一对夫妇试图抚养一个无性别儿童的故事。《X的故事》轰动一时。它最终被改编成一书，并在2016年被改编成一部动画短片。从前，有一个名叫X的婴儿出生了。这个婴儿之所以叫X，是因为没人能分清它是男孩还是女孩。当然，它的父母分得清，但他们不能告诉任何人。你看，这一切都是一个非常重要的秘密科学实验的一部分，它的官方代号是X宝宝计划。
In the story, exasperants keep hitting barriers as they try to raise a child without revealing its gender. Friends and family are furious that they aren't told what the baby is. There were other problems too. Toys, for instance, and clothes on his first shopping trip, Mr. Jones told the store clerk. I need some clothes and toys for instance and clothes. On his first shopping trip Mr. Jones told the store clerk, I need some clothes and toys for my new baby. The clerk smiled and said,
在故事中，当苦恼的父母试图在不透露孩子性别的情况下抚养孩子时，他们不断遇到障碍。朋友和家人对没有被告知婴儿的性别感到愤怒。还有其他问题。例如玩具，还有他第一次购物时的衣服，琼斯先生对店员说。我需要一些衣服和玩具，比如衣服和玩具。在他第一次购物时，琼斯先生对店员说，我需要一些衣服和玩具给我的新宝宝。店员微笑着说：
Well now, is it a boy or a girl? It's an ex. Mr. Jones said smiling back, but the clerk got all red in the face and said, hopefully, Well, in that case, I'm afraid I can't help you, sir." The point of the baby X-tail is to highlight all the ways gender stereotypes act as rules for children from the clothes they wear to the sports they play to the interests they're encouraged to pursue. Now Royce and Jessica weren't trying to hide that daughter's gender, they just wanted her to grow up without all the stereotypes attached to being a girl.
好吧，现在，这是个男孩还是女孩？是个X。琼斯先生微笑着回答，但店员满脸通红地说，如果那样的话，恐怕我帮不了你，先生。X宝宝故事的重点在于突显性别刻板印象作为儿童规则的所有方式，从他们穿的衣服到他们玩的运动，再到鼓励他们追求的兴趣。现在，罗伊斯和杰西卡并不是想隐藏女儿的性别，他们只是想让她在成长过程中摆脱作为女孩所附带的所有刻板印象。
Jessica devoured articles on gender and parenting. Sorted Royce, reading late into the night, under his bed covers by flashlight. They didn't label their evolving child-waring philosophy, but these days, we'd call it gender-neutral parenting. They had strong views on what would and wouldn't be good for their daughter. Toys, we had started talking about, you know, we're not going to, we're not going to be getting her baby dolls and Barbies and we want her to have open-ended free play toys. Like blocks and big Legos.
杰西卡如饥似渴地阅读关于性别和育儿的文章。罗伊斯也是，深夜打着手电筒在被窝里阅读到很晚。他们没有给他们不断演变的育儿哲学贴上标签，但今天，我们会称之为中性育儿。对于什么对女儿好，什么不好，他们有强烈的看法。关于玩具，我们开始讨论，你知道的，我们不打算，不打算给她买婴儿娃娃和芭比娃娃，我们希望她拥有开放式的自由玩耍玩具。比如积木和大型乐高。
And we want a toys that had animals and lots of and lots of bright colors instead of bright, bright primary colors instead of just pastel pink and princess or fairy motifs. And so they planned and waited. They decided on a name, ISIS, after the fierce Egyptian goddess and symbol of powerful womanhood. Isis had her own plans. On November 7, 2000, she was born two months premature. She was rushed to the neonatal intensive care unit or the NICU. Now, all that Royce and Jessica wanted was for Isis to survive. When Isis was in the neonatal, she needed to nurse every two hours. And so we lived less than a little under a mile away, and so we had to go every two hours, which means that in the feeding took a good,
我们希望玩具里有动物，还有很多很多的鲜艳色彩，而不是明亮的、鲜艳的原色，而不仅仅是柔和的粉红色和公主或仙女图案。于是他们计划着，等待着。他们决定了一个名字——伊西斯（Isis），取自凶猛的埃及女神和强大女性气概的象征。伊西斯有她自己的计划。2000年11月7日，她早产两个月出生了。她被紧急送往新生儿重症监护室，也就是NICU。现在，罗伊斯和杰西卡唯一的愿望就是伊西斯能活下来。当伊西斯在新生儿重症监护室时，她每两个小时就需要喂奶一次。所以我们住的地方离得不到一英里，所以我们必须每两个小时去一次，这意味着喂奶需要花一个很好的，
you know, 45 minutes from start to finish. And so, right. And so we would, and then we would go home, you know, catch 20 minutes, 30 minutes of sleep, get back up and go right back. It was exhausting. And in this atmosphere of breathing machines and monitors, Jessica had her first big end counter with gender stereotypes.
你知道的，从开始到结束要45分钟。所以，没错。所以我们会，然后我们会回家，你知道的，抓紧睡上20分钟、30分钟，然后再爬起来马上回去。这太累人了。在这个充满呼吸机和监护仪的环境中，杰西卡迎来了她与性别刻板印象的第一次重大遭遇。
At one point, the nurses were concerned about both ISIS and Jessica and they made a suggestion. They said, you know what? I think you and the baby are stressed out. And I think that why don't you let us give her a bottle and you go home and take a nap. And we lived about a mile or so from the hospital. So I left my baby and I think we probably had her like in yellow and green maybe.
有一段时间，护士们对伊西斯和杰西卡都很担心，她们提出了一个建议。她们说，你知道吗？我觉得你和宝宝都压力太大了。我想，为什么不让我们给她喂奶瓶，你回家小睡一会儿呢。我们住的地方离医院大约有一英里左右。所以我离开了我的宝宝，我想我们当时可能给她穿的是黄色和绿色的衣服吧。
I wasn't trying to dress her like a boy. You know, I just wanted to have what I consider to be neutral colors. Had her in just some regular sleeper and I came back to find the little box that my little baby was in, was shrouded in pink and lace and fluff. And inside my little baby had ribbons in her hair. I don't even know how this is possible. It had been like dunked in a pepto bismobottle in pink, everything. And the nurses were so excited to see how I was going
我并没有试图把她打扮成男孩。你知道的，我只是想穿我认为是中性颜色的衣服。给她穿了一件普通的连体衣，当我回来时，发现我的小宝宝所在的那个小箱子被粉红色、蕾丝和蓬松物包裹着。在里面，我的小宝宝头发上系着缎带。我甚至不知道这怎么可能。它就像被浸泡在一瓶健胃消食露里一样，粉红色，到处都是粉红色。护士们非常兴奋地想看看我看到她们这样做会有什么反应。她们觉得，我当时在家里休息。而我却惊呆了。
to react to that they had done this. And they think for me, why was that home resting? And I was horrified. Now Jessica's reaction might seem extreme. It was a gesture of kindness after all, and ISIS was just a newborn. She wouldn't remember. That's not how Jessica sees it.
现在杰西卡的反响可能看起来很极端。毕竟这是一个善意的举动，而且伊西斯才刚出生。她不会记得的。杰西卡可不这么看。
I was instantly validated in my anger by somebody who was visiting another baby nearby who turned and looked at my baby in my arms, my little pink baby doll, and said, oh, she's so precious and delicate and dainty. And I was enraged. I said, you know what? We're in the NICU, and we want to go home, and we're not going for precious and dainty and delicate.
附近另一个婴儿的访客转过身来，看着我怀里的宝宝，我那个粉红色的小娃娃，说，哦，她是那么的珍贵、娇小和秀气，我的愤怒立刻得到了证实，我被激怒了。我说，你知道吗？我们在重症监护室，我们想回家，我们不追求珍贵、娇小和秀气。
That's not what I want. We're going for strong and powerful and healthy. Language mattered to Jessica. I noticed that from that moment, how other people would talk to her, and I felt words are powerful, and right now we want all of our energy to be towards growth and strength and power. What Jessica was realizing is something marketers have long understood. Language sends a powerful signal. We pulled some toy ads from the early 2000s when ISIS was a baby. And what we heard over and over were two distinct tones, one for boys and one for girls. Hot Wheels leading the way!
这不是我想要的。我们要的是强壮、强大和健康。语言对杰西卡来说很重要。从那一刻起，我注意到其他人是如何与她对话的，我觉得言语是充满力量的，现在我们希望将所有的精力都投入到成长、力量和权力中。杰西卡所意识到的是营销人员早就理解的事情。语言发出了强有力的信号。我们找来了一些2000年代初伊西斯还是婴儿时的玩具广告。我们一遍又一遍听到的是两种截然不同的语气，一种针对男孩，一种针对女孩。“风火轮”领先！
Little Hot Wheels, Thunder Roll and Racing game! Now you can take a Hot Wheels car and really drive it! Is that your baby sister? No, it's her little baby. Hush little baby! Why? Because you do the girls' little baby's team. She's crying!
小“风火轮”，雷鸣滚动和赛车游戏！现在你可以拿着一把“风火轮”汽车，真正地驾驶它！那是你的小妹妹吗？不，是她的洋娃娃。嘘，小宝贝！为什么？因为你做的是女孩的小宝贝团队。她在哭！
She just wants a battle. Hush little baby, looks and sounds so real. You think she's a real baby. To Jessica, messages like these were about much more than dolls and tea parties. The clothes ISIS wore, even as a preemie in the NICU, changed the way the world behaved toward her. When my baby is in what people consider to be boys clothes, yellow, they would say, oh, look at that strong baby. You are doing great. You're growing so big and so fast.
她只是想要个奶瓶。嘘，小宝贝，看起来和听起来都那么真实。你以为她是个真正的婴儿。在杰西卡看来，这样的信息远不止洋娃娃和茶话会那么简单。伊西斯穿的衣服，哪怕是在重症监护室里的早产儿时期，也改变了世界对待她的方式。当我的宝宝穿着人们认为是男孩衣服的黄色衣服时，他们会说，哦，看那个强壮的宝宝。你做得真棒。你长得又大又快。
And when she was in that pink outfit, all of a sudden she was dainty and delicate. Here was all the stuff that she'd read about made real. It galvanized Jessica to walk the walk and not just talk the talk. To be the change she wanted to see. I'm right. I'm right about this. And that's exactly what I want.
而当她穿着那套粉红色的衣服时，她突然就变得娇小而秀气了。她读过的所有关于这方面的资料都在现实中上演了。这激励着杰西卡去践行自己的理念，而不仅仅是纸上谈兵。成为她希望看到的改变。我是对的。我在这件事上是对的。这正是我想要的。
I'm not just now, not just getting strong enough to go home and leave the hospital and be healthy. This is what I want for her for her whole life. I want her to feel like she is strong and powerful. Jessica and Royce thought if they could just make it past the NICU, the hardest part would be over. They were wrong. This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vidantam. When Jessica and Royce, a young interracial couple, found out they were having a daughter,
我不仅仅是现在，不仅仅是为了变得足够强壮以离开医院并保持健康。这是我为她的一生所想要的。我希望她觉得自己是强壮而有力量的。杰西卡和罗伊斯以为，只要他们能熬过重症监护室的阶段，最艰难的部分就结束了。他们错了。这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是香卡·维丹塔姆。当杰西卡和罗伊斯这对年轻的跨种族夫妇发现他们将拥有一个女儿时，
they decided to raise her free of gender stereotypes. It was an idealistic goal that turned out to be far more complicated than they imagined. Their daughter, Isis, was born early and spent the first two weeks of her life in the neonatal intensive care unit. When Royce and Jessica left the hospital, they thought that things would get easier. But they quickly found that their choices for their own family set people spinning. Here was Royce, a black man in a Coast Guard uniform, his biracial child in a sling. When strangers would peek at the child Royce says, they'd look at him, confused, and they'd see the same thing again and again. Oh, well, I can't tell what your baby is.
他们决定抚养她远离性别刻板印象。这是一个理想主义的目标，结果却比他们想象的要复杂得多。他们的女儿伊西斯早产，在新生儿重症监护室度过了生命的前两周。当杰西卡和罗伊斯离开医院时，他们以为事情会变得容易一些。但他们很快发现，他们为自己家庭做出的选择让人们不知所措。看呐，罗伊斯，一个身穿海岸警卫队制服的黑人男性，他的混血孩子坐在背带里。当陌生人瞥一眼孩子时，罗伊斯说，他们看着他，感到困惑，他们一次又一次地看到同样的情景。哦，好吧，我分不清你的孩子是什么性别。
And I'm like, it's baby. And so, it's just that whole, not just the yearning to know what the sex was, but not knowing how to interact in a situation without knowing what gender the baby was. And this is what Jessica heard. Do you wish that your baby was a boy? Are you sad that you had a girl? And I was, what are you, where is that coming from? What do you mean? Of course, I'm not sad that I have a girl. I'm so excited to have a girl. I just don't think that having a daughter has to mean this particular thing or that being a girl has to mean she's still a girl.
而我想说，这就是个婴儿。所以，这不仅仅是渴望知道性别是什么，而是不知道如何在不知道婴儿性别的情况下进行互动。而这是杰西卡听到的。你希望你的宝宝是个男孩吗？你生了个女孩很难过吗？而我当时想，你这是什么，这都是从哪儿来的？什么意思？我当然不难过我生了个女孩。我很高兴能生个女孩。我只是不认为生个女儿就非得意味着某种特定的事情，或者身为女孩就意味着她必须依然是个女孩。
She's still a girl if she's wearing bright primary colors and not wearing pink. The subtle questioning grew, and it wasn't just strangers who didn't understand who asked, what's the big deal? Why make things so difficult? It was their own family. We had family who said, well, it, you know, in sending another dress when we
如果她穿着鲜艳的原色而不是粉红色，她依然是个女孩。微妙的质问增多了，不仅是陌生人不理解，还问，这有什么大不了的？为什么要让事情变得这么困难？这是他们自己的家人。我们有家人说，好吧，当我们在
had said that we were not going to use it and other people in the family said, you know, what, you don't find, don't. But take a picture of the baby in the dress, send them the picture, and then give the dress away. And I said, no, I'm not, I'm not going to do that. I don't, I don't want to do that. I don't feel like I, I should have to do that. And another dress came in the mail again and we asked for them to send, you know, nobody has to buy you anything, but if somebody is spending their money on you
说过我们不打算使用它时，却又寄来了另一条裙子，家里其他人说，你知道吗，你不用，别。但给穿着裙子的宝宝拍张照片，把照片寄过去，然后把裙子送人。我说，不，我不会，我才不那样做。我不想，我不想那样做。我觉得我，我不应该非得那样做。又有一条裙子寄来了，我们要求他们寄，你知道的，没有人必须给你买任何东西，但如果有人把钱花在你身上，
and ask you, we, they would ask us for suggestions and we would try to give other suggestions of things that we needed and we were still, we were still instead receiving these dresses. And this family members feelings were really hurt and they said that they were not sure if they could have a relationship with our daughter. If they were not going to be able to understand how to relate to her, I didn't understand what dresses had to do with how they were going to relate to her, but it obviously triggered some really emotional reactions in some of our family members.
并向你征求意见时，我们会尽量提供我们需要的其他东西的建议，而我们依然，依然还是收到了这些裙子。这位家庭成员的感情真的很受伤，他们说他们不确定是否能与我们的女儿保持关系。如果他们无法理解如何与她相处的话，我不明白裙子跟他们如何与她相处有什么关系，但这显然引发了我们某些家庭成员非常情绪化的反应。
Emotional reactions that never expected. It was as if others took their decisions regarding ISIS as a personal insult. To strangers, they were insufferable, politically correct, do-gooders. To family, they were causing trouble, maybe even harming their little girl. Jessica and Royce felt they were fighting a tide of unconscious biases, but everyone seemed to think they were fighting a tide of unconscious biases, but everyone seemed to think they were the problem. And sometimes, when they fought against one norm, they ran into problems with another.
从未预料到的情绪化反应。就好像其他人把他们对伊西斯的决定当作是对个人的侮辱。对陌生人来说，他们是惹人厌烦、政治正确的好事者。对家人来说，他们是在惹麻烦，甚至可能在伤害他们的小女孩。杰西卡和罗伊斯觉得他们在逆着潜意识偏见的潮流而上，但每个人似乎都认为他们是问题所在。有时，当他们对抗一种规范时，又会遇到另一种规范的问题。
Jessica tells of one particularly painful interaction, after I says decided she wanted to cut her hair. You know, my daughter wanted her hair cut short, and I didn't have any issue with that because it's her hair. And I was told someone who I really respect and care about and love told me that it was inappropriate for me to have done that because I don't have the ability to understand the cultural dynamics around black women's hair and black girls' hair. And she said, for instance, women who were slaves in the United States, their hair was shorn and cut short against their will.
杰西卡讲述了一次特别痛苦的互动，那是在伊西斯决定剪短头发之后。你知道的，我女儿想剪短发，我对此没有任何意见，因为那是她的头发。而我被告知，一个我非常尊敬、关心和爱的人告诉我，我那样做是不合适的，因为我不具备理解黑人女性头发和黑人女孩头发周围文化动态的能力。她说，例如，在美国作为奴隶的女性，她们的头发是在违背她们意愿的情况下被剪短的。
And so that was something that, you know, that we have like triggers, right? That this person, seeing me me cut my daughter's hair short was painful for her. It was like that saying, they pulled on one thread, and the whole cloth started to unravel. This is, I think, what happens when you start to break social norms, other unanticipated social norms also get broken like lines of communication.
所以那是某些事情，你知道的，我们有某种触发点，对吧？这个人看到我把女儿的头发剪短会感到痛苦。这就好比那句俗语，他们扯动了一条线，整块布就开始散架了。我认为，这就是当你开始打破社会规范时发生的事情，其他未曾预料到的社会规范也会被打破，比如沟通的渠道。
And so it was really hard for us in the beginning. And we did. We felt ostracized, but we knew we were doing it to ourselves. And we also knew that it was important. Still, that didn't make it any easier, especially with family. They became estranged from Royce's mother for many years. The tension with their siblings was thick. What we tried to say to our family is,
所以这在开始时对我们来说真的很难。我们确实这样做了。我们感到被排挤，但我们知道这是我们自找的。我们也知道这很重要。尽管如此，这并没有让事情变得更容易，尤其是对家人而言。他们与罗伊斯的母亲疏远了多年。他们与兄弟姐妹之间的紧张关系非常深厚。我们试图对家人说的是，
this is not an assessment or a judgment of you and how you choose to do things or how you may have chosen to do things in the past. It has nothing to do with that. It has to do with what we want right now for this particular child, our first child in our family. Did you ever have any moments of self doubt where you sort of said, you know, I might be hurting my child
这并不是对你以及你选择做事的方式或你过去可能选择做事的方式的评估或判断。这与此无关。这与我们现在对这个特定的孩子，我们家族中的第一个孩子的期望有关。你有没有过任何自我怀疑的时刻，你有点说，你知道的，我可能会伤害我的孩子，
in the interest of some abstract intellectual goal? I mean, having my daughter sobbing because a little boy wanted her to take her clothes off and prove that she's a girl on the playground because she has short hair and she's wearing primary colors and doesn't look like a girl. And of course, she wasn't going to do that. But the fact that somebody would even suggest that that would be something that should be done, you know, that that was horrifying.
为了某个抽象的理智目标？我是说，我的女儿因为一个小男孩在游乐场上想让她脱掉衣服证明她是个女孩而泣不成声，因为她留着短发，穿着原色衣服，看起来不像个女孩。当然，她是不会那样做的。但竟然有人会建议应该去做那种事，你知道的，这太可怕了。
And so that there are those moments that like, okay. Is this something that we created? Is this a problem that is this pain that we created for our daughter? And I would say, no. That pain was created by the idea that it matters, the way that somebody moves in the world expressing their sex or gender or that that even matters when you're playing on the playground. I think that's the issue.
所以会有那些时刻，比如，好吧。这是我们制造的事情吗？这是我们为女儿制造的问题，是这种痛苦吗？我会说，不。这种痛苦是由这种观念制造的：一个人在世界中表达其生理性别或社会性别的方式很重要，或者当你在游乐场玩耍时这甚至很重要。我认为这才是问题所在。
That's the problem. Jessica and Royce never saw what they were doing as an experiment. Now were they trying to keep ISIS from being feminine? They just wanted her to discover for herself what she wanted and not have a label restrict her choices. I felt like we were trying to give her as many opportunities to figure out what she really likes and who she really is and her clothes and her toys. those are functional items. Those were not items that were meant to be an identity for her. Her coat was to keep her warm, and her shoes were to keep her feet safe.
这才是问题。杰西卡和罗伊斯从来不把他们做的事情看作是一个实验。他们也不是试图阻止伊西斯变得女性化。他们只是想让她自己去发现她想要什么，而不让一个标签限制了她的选择。我觉得我们是在试图给她尽可能多的机会去弄清楚她真正喜欢什么，以及她真正在服装和玩具上是谁。那些是功能性物品。这些并不是为了成为她身份象征的物品。她的外套是为了给她保暖，她的鞋子是为了保护她的脚的安全。
Still, if ISIS had wanted fancy and practical dresses when she was young, Jessica says she wouldn't have just said no. At any point where she expressed to me that she wants, you know, a Cinderella dress to wear, I would be curious about, I'd like to hear a little bit more about that. And then, you know, gosh, this poor kid, then I'd be like, well, you know, we gotta try to find one that maybe wasn't made
尽管如此，如果伊西斯在小时候想要穿华丽又实用的裙子，杰西卡说她不会直接说不。在她向我表达她希望穿，你知道的，一件灰姑娘的裙子穿在身上的任何时候，我都会很好奇，我想多听听这方面的想法。然后，你知道的，天哪，这个可怜的孩子，然后我会想，好吧，你知道的，我们得试着找一件可能不是由其他国家的工厂里的儿童制作的裙子，
by other children in a factory, and another, you know, another part of the world. So right, sometimes can we just go to Walmart like everybody else and buy something? But of course, the answer is no. Royce and Jessica want to be the change even when it's hard. There was a lot of loss involved. And yet when they wondered, is it worth it? They came to the same conclusion that Julia Butterfly Hill reached as she defended her redwood tree
在世界的另一个地方。所以没错，有时我们难道不能像其他人一样去沃尔玛买点东西吗？但当然，答案是否定的。罗伊斯和杰西卡想要成为改变本身，即使这很艰难。其中牵涉到许多失去。然而，当他们纳闷，这值得吗？他们得出了与茱莉亚·巴特弗莱·希尔在保卫她的红杉树时得出的相同的结论，
that Levoi Finnecom reached as he challenged the federal government and that Franklin McCain reached at that Woolworth lunch counter in 1960. Yes, it is worth it. The personal choices that I make in fighting against those ideologies that I find problematic are absolutely because I find them problematic. And I use all of every means necessary I have to fighting in those ideologies. Jessica and Royce believe it's the little things, the ones that might at the time seem inconsequential.
与莱沃伊·菲尼库姆在挑战联邦政府时得出的结论，以及与富兰克林·麦凯恩在1960年那个伍尔沃斯午餐柜台上得出的结论一样。是的，这是值得的。我在反对那些我发现有问题的意识形态时所做出的个人选择，绝对是因为我发现它们有问题。我用我拥有的一切必要手段来反对这些意识形态。杰西卡和罗伊斯相信，这是小事，是那些在当时看起来微不足道的事。
Those are the ones you need to pay attention to. Because in the end, systems of unfairness are just the sum of many small choices. Change doesn't happen in dramatic moments. When we're talking about trying to make long-term, systematic shifts, these happen in the little decisions that we make every day and the little interactions that we have every day. And the power of a system is such that I don't think that we're helpless victims in the
这些正是你需要关注的事。因为到头来，不公平的系统不过是许多小选择的总和。改变不会发生在戏剧性的时刻。当我们谈论试图做出长期的、系统性的转变时，这些转变发生在我们在每一天做出的微小决定中，以及我们在每一天进行的微小互动中。而系统的力量在于，我不认为我们是系统中的无助受害者，但我认为系统有其自身的生命力。在让女孩和女性将时间和精力花在购买产品和服装来改变她们的外表之间，存在着巨大的资本驱动力。所以在我们的生活中存在着不同种类的驱动力，有些文化规范可能是我们带着爱传承下来的，但它们最初可能是由营销人员发起的。你知道的。
system, but I think that the system has its own life force. There's a huge capitalist drive between having girls and women spend their time and energy on buying products and clothes to change the way that they look. So there are different kinds of driving forces in our lives, there are cultural norms that maybe we pass down with love, but maybe they were initially started by a marketer. You know.
系统，但我认为系统本身有它自己的生命力。在让女孩和女人花费时间和精力购买产品和衣服来改变外表这件事情背后，存在着巨大的资本主义驱动力。所以我们的生活中存在着各种各样的驱动力，有些文化规范可能是我们带着爱意传下来的，但它们最初可能就是由营销人员发起的，你知道的。
After all the effort Royce and Jessica put in, I had to wonder, did any of it make a difference? Jessica and Royce believe it did. They felt that as ISIS grew, she embraced and internalized the power that they were offering her. When we come back, we'll hear from ISIS about how it turned out.
在罗伊斯和杰 Jessica 付出了这么多努力之后，我不得不思考，这一切真的有什么改变吗？杰西卡和罗伊斯相信是有的。他们觉得随着 ISIS 的成长，她接受并内化了他们赋予她的力量。当我们回来时，我们将听到 ISIS 关于结果如何的看法。
One third I got from my dad, one third I got from my mom, and one third is all me. Stay with us. This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantam. We've been hearing about a couple, Roy Sanjesaika, who tried to keep gender stereotypes at Bay as they raised their daughter. I got a chance to meet that daughter, ISIS, when she and her family stopped by NPR on their way home from a month-long road trip. I'm Shankar. I'm road trip. I'm Sean Der.
三分之一来自我爸爸，三分之一来自我妈妈，还有三分之一全靠我自己。请继续收听。这里是 Hidden Brain，我是香卡·韦丹塔姆。我们一直在听一对夫妇 Roy Sanjesaika 的故事，他们在抚养女儿的过程中尽量避免性别刻板印象。我有机会见到那个女儿 ISIS，当时她和家人从一个月的公路旅行回来，顺道去了 NPR。我是香卡。我是公路旅行。我是肖恩·德尔。
I'm Sean Der. It's so nice to meet you. It's nice to meet you too. I feel like I know so much about you, I say. I feel like I know you really well. I feel like I really good sport too, just waking up then. ISIS is 16 now, thinking about college and her future. She's no longer an only child.
我是肖恩·德尔。很高兴见到你。我也很高兴见到你。我觉得我好像对你了解很多，我说。我觉得我真的很了解你。我觉得我也表现得很好，刚刚醒来。ISIS 现在 16 岁了，正在考虑大学和她的未来。她不再是独生子女了。
She has three siblings. Yeah, Maya's 11. A low-runer's 9. Oh! You wanted them to guess and Sati is 5. and only child. She has three siblings. While the other kids in Jessica took a tour of NPR, Royce, Isis and I sat down together. Isis has a quick smile, a head full of curly locks, and a sharp sense of humor. My mom is in Divinity School. I could joke that I dress more professionally than she does. What strikes me immediately about ISIS is her self-confidence. It's just part of who she is. It also comes through in the stories she tells about her childhood. When she was just three years old, ISIS decided she wanted to take horseback riding lessons. Her parents told her she was too young, that the minimum riding age at most stables was five. But ISIS was insistent, so they found
她有三个兄弟姐妹。是的，玛雅 11 岁。A low-runer's 9 岁。哦！你想让他们猜，萨蒂 5 岁。还有独生子女。她有三个兄弟姐妹。当其他孩子和杰西卡参观 NPR 时，罗伊斯、伊西斯和我坐在一起。伊西斯笑容灿烂，满头卷发，有着敏锐的幽默感。我妈妈在神学院。我可以开玩笑说，我的穿着比她更职业。伊西斯立刻给我留下深刻印象的是她的自信。这正是她本色的一部分。这也体现在她讲述的童年故事中。ISIS 三岁时，决定去学骑马。她的父母告诉她她太小了，大多数马厩的最低骑马年龄是五岁。但伊西斯坚持要去，所以他们找到了
an instructor who was willing to let her try. I got on, and this was the first time I'd ever ridden, and I was like, oh my gosh, mommy, I'm riding, and I hadn't realized yet that you shouldn't shout, and being was like, oh my gosh, there's a child shouting on me and totally reared up, but I stuck my seat. And she came down and I was still there and fine. And John was like, OK, you can ride and I've been riding ever since. This is what Jessica and Royce wanted.
一位愿意让她尝试的教练。我上去了，这是我第一次骑马，当时我想，哦天哪，妈妈，我在骑马，我还没意识到你不应该大喊大叫，马就像，哦天哪，有个小孩对我大喊大叫，然后完全直立起来，但我抓紧了马鞍。它下来了，我还坐在上面，很好。约翰说，好吧，你可以骑了，我从那以后就一直在骑。这就是杰西卡和罗伊斯想要的。
What they dreamed of since ISIS was in the neonatal intensive care unit, a strong and powerful daughter who knew her own mind. Another thing that Royce and Jessica did was to home school ISIS. It was one way they believed to give the child unfettered space to grow. Again, Royce says, it was about trying to keep unnecessary rules at bay. There's not a whole lot of you will do this, this, and this.'s a lot of what do you want to talk about, what do you want to learn, come
这是他们从伊西斯在新生儿重症监护室时就梦寐以求的，一个坚强有力、有主见的女儿。罗伊斯和杰西卡做的另一件事是让伊西斯在家上学。他们认为这是给孩子提供不受束缚的成长空间的一种方式。罗伊斯再次表示，这是为了尽量不让不必要的规则阻碍孩子的发展。没有多少“你会做这个、这个和这个”，有很多“你想谈什么，你想学什么，来
ask me questions when you need help with figuring things out and varying degrees of that. Royce comes from a family of educators and many of them found these ideas unsettling. It's really easy I think to see how they could be alarmed by you know oh gosh Royce read some book and now he's like, gonna ruin, you know, my niece. And so I think that it's not that everybody ever said that to me out loud. I don't know if they thought that or not, but I can see how easily that that could take that idea can take shape in someone's head. There
当你需要帮助解决问题时向我提问”，并且有不同程度的这样做。罗伊斯来自一个教育工作者家庭，他们中的许多人发现这些想法令人不安。我认为很容易看出他们怎么会为此感到震惊，哦天哪，罗伊斯读了一本书，现在他要，你知道的，毁了，你知道的，我的侄女。所以我认为并不是每个人都对我说过这样的话。我不知道他们是否这么想，但我可以明白这种想法是多么容易在某人的脑海中形成。那里
was a lot of questioning about, well, you know, how are you gonna know that they know everything that they need to know in order to progress. What if they never learn to write? Right? What if they never learn to read? What if they don't know how to do mathematics? And my pushback to that, or not even pushback, my answer was that, you know, naturally humans are curious. And when given space and time to have conversation they're going to be curious about their world and they're going to figure out ways to do things. This is at the heart of Royce's educational philosophy.
有很多质疑，比如，你知道的，你怎么能知道他们知道他们需要知道的一切以便取得进步。如果他们从来没有学会写作怎么办？对吧？如果他们从来没有学会阅读怎么办？如果他们不知道如何做数学怎么办？我对这一点的反击，或者甚至不是反击，我的回答是，你知道，人类天生就是好奇的。当给予空间和时间来进行对话时，他们会对自己的世界感到好奇，并且会想出做事的方法。这是罗伊斯教育哲学的核心。
People do their best, he believes, when they're motivated by their own passion and drive. And I think that internal motivation is what actually serves you later when you're trying to do things like complex mathematics, complex science. So I really feel like this whole generous stratification really breaks down to how are you motivated. Royce gives this example. When ISIS was young, he often brought her with him when he was teaching at the Coast Guard Academy. When ISIS would come to school with me and I'd ask questions in my class, to my college students, the cadets, and they may or may not know the answer, but they would be completely inhibited or not paying attention. In class, and so Isis was doing both. She was paying attention and she was uninhibited,
他相信，当人们受到自己的热情和驱动力激励时，会发挥出最好的一面。我认为正是这种内在的动机，在你后来试图做诸如复杂数学、复杂科学之类的事情时，真正对你有所帮助。所以我真的觉得所有这些代际分层实际上归结为你如何被激励。罗伊斯举了这样一个例子。伊西斯很小的时候，他经常带着她去海岸警卫队学院教书。当伊西斯和我一起去学校，我在课堂上向我的学生、大学学员提问时，他们可能知道也可能不知道答案，但他们会完全受到抑制或不专心。在课堂上，伊西斯两者兼顾。她既专心又无拘无束，
so if I had asked a question, she would answer it. And so the cadets would look at her at this, you know, six, seven-year-old and say, how is she, what are you doing at home to train her? Or is it to where she's got to be doing some major physics at home? And I'm like, well, no. She has a question about how the world works. Of course, we talk it through, and I have some insight that maybe other parents don't. But a lot of the stuff that I'm doing right now in this class, we've never even talked about.
所以如果我问了一个问题，她就会回答。因此，那些学员看着这个，你知道的，六、七岁的孩子说，她在做什么，你在家里做些什么来训练她？还是说她在家里必须做一些重大的物理学？我说，好吧，不。她对世界是如何运作的有一个疑问。当然，我们讨论过了，我有一些其他父母可能没有的见解。但我现在在这节课上做的很多事情，我们甚至从未讨论过。
Like, we've never talked about fluids in Bernoulli's equation. And so, but she's answering questions because she's uninhibited, and she's not afraid to ask questions. Isis excelled at math and science, and of course horseback riding. When she was in her early teens, Isis desperately wanted to attend a summer camp focused on large animal veterinary medicine, but the camp was too expensive. Rather than give up, ISIS took the initiative to raise the money herself. So we set up a website for fundraising. I made, because I'm a fiber artist,
就像，我们从来没有讨论过流体和伯努利方程。但是她在回答问题，因为她无拘无束，她不怕问问题。伊西斯在数学和科学方面表现出色，当然还有骑马。在她的青少年早期，伊西斯非常渴望参加一个专注于大型动物兽医学的夏令营，但夏令营太贵了。伊西斯没有放弃，而是主动自己筹集资金。所以我们建立了一个筹款网站。我制作了，因为我是纤维艺术家，
so I made things for the people who gave a certain amount of money, and I went to this camp. It was my first time being away for more than a week, and it was really awesome camp. ISIS is busy these days. Besides her academics, she has steady work, walking dogs, and cleaning stalls at the horse barn where she still rides. She loves to read books, and she does not much like the colour pink. You know, I've never really been a pink person on the edge of appreciating purple, and my
所以我为那些捐赠了一定金额的人制作东西，然后我去了这个营地。这是我第一次离开家超过一周，这是一个非常棒的营地。伊西斯这些日子很忙。除了学业，她还有稳定的工作，遛狗，在骑马的马厩里清理马厩。她喜欢读书，而且不太喜欢粉红色。你知道的，我从来都不是一个粉红色的人，处于欣赏紫色的边缘，而且我的
favourite colour has always been blue. And it is a colour blue that leads ISIS to a story about how sometimes it was hard growing up with parents who believed in gender neutral clothes and toys. When ISIS was 8, she told me, her parents agreed to buy her her first bike. At the store, she found her dream bike. It was my favorite color of blue, and it had like the skirt bend in it, and I just wanted it so badly, but my dad said no because my brother had been born. Royce and Jessica believed in gender neutral parenting for their son as well. A boy with a blue bike that would just be following the usual script. Another thing Ices didn't mention is that the bike also had frills. Obviously a no-go. But you know moved on. Got a bike that had a blue stripe on it, which was okay. It was very devastating for an eight-year-old to not be able to get the bike that
最喜欢的颜色一直是蓝色。正是蓝色让伊西斯想到了一个故事，关于有时和相信中性服装和玩具的父母一起长大是多么艰难。伊西斯 8 岁时告诉我，她的父母同意给她买第一辆自行车。在店里，她找到了她梦想中的自行车。这是我最喜欢的蓝色，它有裙子弯曲的设计，我太想要了，但我爸爸说不，因为我弟弟出生了。罗伊斯和杰西卡也为他们的儿子实行中性育儿。一个骑着蓝色自行车的男孩只会遵循通常的剧本。伊西斯没有提到的另一件事是，这辆自行车还有褶边。显然这是不行的。但你知道生活还得继续。买了一辆带蓝色条纹的自行车，这还可以。对于一个八岁的孩子来说，不能买那辆你想要的自行车是非常毁灭性的
you wanted. But I can understand now. ISIS says it was sometimes painful to be raised in a gender neutral way. Because I had to tell people that I wasn't a boy, and sometimes people wouldn't believe me when I said that I wasn't a boy, especially children, which was ridiculous. With her dad looking on, I asked ISIS whether it had been too much. Did you feel like your parents ever went too far? Um... Don't look at me like that. I'm just curious. Did you feel like your parents ever went too far? Um... Don't look at me like that. I'm just curious.
你想。但我现在可以理解了。伊西斯说，以性别中立的方式抚养有时是痛苦的。因为我必须告诉别人我不是个男孩，有时当我告诉别人我不是个男孩时，人们不相信我，尤其是孩子们，这太荒谬了。在她的爸爸的注视下，我问伊西斯这是否太过分了。你觉得你的父母有没有太过分的时候？嗯……别那样看着我。我只是好奇。你觉得你的父母有没有太过分的时候？嗯……别那样看着我。我只是好奇。
Are you putting on the pressure? Um... You sound like someone who can deal with pressure. Yes, that's why I did my... ...breathy voice. But um... I don't know. I can't think of a specific time where it was like that.
你在施加压力吗？嗯……你听起来像是一个能应对压力的人。是的，这就是我做我的…………喘息的声音的原因。但是嗯……我不知道。我想不出有什么特定的时候是那样的。
I think that I've, I think that they gave me the freedom that I needed. And I've never, they've never said blatantly, No, you can not wear this. Or no, you can absolutely not do this. And I can't, yeah, I think it's been generally pretty good. Mainly, the stories that come tumbling out of ISIS tell of a girl who lives her life with determination. She grew up climbing trees and digging worms for their chickens and helping her younger siblings She's also surprisingly candid about her gender and her sexuality When we sat down for our interview like I do with all guests. I asked Isis to introduce herself
我想我，我想他们给了我需要的自由。而且我从来没有，他们从来没有公然说过，不，你不能穿这个。或者不，你绝对不能这样做。并且我不能，是的，我认为总的来说相当不错。主要是，从伊西斯口中倾泻而出的故事讲述了一个充满决心生活的女孩。她从小爬树，为鸡挖蚯蚓，帮助年幼的兄弟姐妹。对于自己的性别和性取向，她也出奇地坦诚。当我们坐下来接受采访时，就像我对所有客人所做的那样。我请伊西斯做个自我介绍
Here's what she said I'm Isis James Collins. I'm 16 years old My pronouns are she, her and hers. I identify sexually as bisexual. It was a powerful moment. Isis seems to know who she is. She is a girl and yet she doesn't seem at all confined by traditional gender constraints. She can like boys and girls.
她是这样说的：我是伊西斯·詹姆斯·柯林斯。我 16 岁。我的代词是 she, her 和 hers。我在性取向上认同为双性恋。这是一个强有力的时刻。伊西斯似乎知道她是谁。她是一个女孩，然而她似乎一点也没有被传统的性别规范所束缚。她可以喜欢男孩和女孩。
She is comfortable in writing boots and in high heels. She can be herself. So, one of the things that has fascinated me and I've been always wondering as I talked with your parents is, I mean, you've obviously turned into a wonderful young woman, you are self-confident, you are happy, you are cheerful, you explore things. I mean, you are every parent's dream child. Thank you. I'm wondering,, you are every parent's dream child. Thank you. I'm wondering, would you have turned out differently if they had parented you differently?
她穿着马靴和高跟鞋都很自在。她可以做她自己。所以，一直让我着迷的一件事，也是我和你父母交谈时一直在想的，我的意思是，你显然已经成长为一个优秀的年轻女性，你很自信，你很快乐，你很开朗，你探索各种事物。我的意思是，你是每个父母梦寐以求的孩子。谢谢你。我想知道，你是每个父母梦寐以求的孩子。谢谢你。我想知道，如果他们用不同的方式抚养你，你的结果会不同吗？
Or is it just, is it possible this is just who ISIS is? This is actually not Royce and Jessica's doing, this is actually all you. Well, this turns into nature, which is nurture, which is a very complicated and highly arguable idea that is through a lot of what we do. And so me personally, I believe that everyone has something that is totally your own. What I say is one third I got from my dad, one third I got from my my mom and one third is all me. And yet, when you think about all of the ways in which the world shapes us, I think we are increasingly realizing that it's really difficult to disentangle the part of us that feels most like us that comes from us
或者这只是，这可能就是伊西斯本来的样子吗？这其实不是罗伊斯和杰西卡的功劳，这其实全靠你自己。好吧，这就变成了先天与后天的问题，这是一个非常复杂且备受争议的概念，贯穿了我们所做的大多数事情。所以就我个人而言，我坚信每个人都有完全属于自己的东西。我说的是三分之一来自我爸爸，三分之一来自我妈妈，还有三分之一全靠我自己。然而，当你考虑到塑造我们的世界的种种方式时，我想我们越来越意识到，很难将那个感觉最像我们、来自我们内部的部分……分离开来。
and the part of us that feels most like us that comes from the outside. And that they both feel exactly the same. They feel like this is who I am. And what we don't realize is that this is who I am, can partly be a social construction, and it can partly be a biological construction, and it can partly be a combination of those two things in ways that are quite unpredictable.
以及那个感觉最像我们、来自外部的部分。而且它们感觉完全一样。它们感觉就像这就是我。而我们没有意识到的是，这就是我，部分可以是一种社会建构，部分可以是一种生物学建构，部分可以是这两种东西以非常不可预测的方式结合的产物。
And the question I want to ask you is, when your parents say, we want her to be who she is, we want her to become who she wants to be, I've always wanted, does that assume that there is a person that we want to be outside of those social influences? Do you see what I'm saying? In other words, is there really something that is genuinely uncontaminated by the outside world that if we allow all of the outside world to be held at bay, that will come and flower up. Or is it actually the case that everything we are is actually shaped by the outside world?
我想问你的问题是，当你的父母说，我们希望她成为她自己，我们希望她成为她想成为的人，我一直想知道，这是否假设在这些社会影响之外，存在着一个我们想要成为的人？你明白我的意思吗？换句话说，真的有什么东西是真正没有被外部世界污染的吗，如果我们允许所有外部世界都被拒之门外，它就会绽放。或者事实真的是，我们的全部其实都是由外部世界塑造的？
And gender neutral parenting is a choice, just like any other choice. And it's going to shape things that you feel are truly intrinsic to yourself that might in fact be the product of your environment. Um, cause and effect is everything. So, you know, it's, I think, me personally, I believe, for me to be myself, to even have the concept of self. I need something that is inherently and undividedly undeluted me. That's just me. And it will always be just me." As their family has grown, Jessica and Royce have tried to maintain their beliefs.
性别中立的育儿方式是一种选择，就像任何其他选择一样。它将塑造你认为对你来说真正内在的东西，而这些东西实际上可能是你环境的产物。嗯，因果关系就是一切。所以，你知道的，我认为，就我个人而言，我相信，为了成为我自己，甚至为了拥有自我的概念。我需要一些本质上不可分割、纯粹属于我的东西。那仅仅是我。而且它永远都只会是我。”随着家庭的壮大，杰西卡和罗伊斯一直试图坚持他们的信念。
They still homeschool all their kids. They still buy clothes and toys that defy stereotypes and encourage exploration. It's gotten easier in some ways. There are more choices now, more parents doing what they do. But Royce says they have also become less confrontational. It's almost like when you first become vegetarian, you are somewhat militant. Right. And then, after a while, you just start to mow out.
他们仍然在家教育所有的孩子。他们仍然购买违背刻板印象并鼓励探索的衣服和玩具。在某些方面变得更容易了。现在有更多的选择，更多的父母在做他们所做的事。但罗伊斯说，他们也变得不那么对抗了。这有点像当你刚成为素食主义者时，你有点激进。对。然后，过了一会儿，你就会开始割草。
And because you're just, you can only be so militant. And so that definitely happened. The way we interacted with people became less militant. And I don't even think that we were trying to be militant in the beginning. It just, that's just the way we were. For her part, Jessica says, she spent a lot of time reflecting on the early days with ISIS. She feels strongly they were doing the right thing, but she regrets how quickly they walked away from those who didn't understand what they were trying to do, especially
因为你只是，你只能那么激进。所以这确实发生了。我们与人互动的方式变得不那么激进。而且我甚至不认为我们一开始就想变得激进。只是，这就是我们的方式。就她而言，杰西卡说，她花了大量时间反思与伊西斯在一起的早期日子。她坚信他们做对了，但她后悔他们这么快就离开了那些不理解他们试图做什么的人，尤其是
family. Things are much better now, but for a long time, they weren't. Sometimes we were maybe too... we didn't change what we did, but we just kind of said, all right, that's your choice. You know, and I think sometimes staying in relationship is staying in there when it, in those hard conversations for longer. And that's what I wish that I had the courage to do. But what they did do also took courage. They were, in a way, pushing against the tide.
家人。现在情况好多了，但有很长一段时间，并不是这样的。有时我们可能太……我们没有改变我们所做的，但我们只是说，好吧，那是你的选择。你知道，而且我认为有时保持关系就是当它处于那些艰难的对话中时，在里面呆得更久。这就是我希望我有勇气去做的事。但他们所做的事也需要勇气。他们在某种程度上是在逆流而上。
When you do make a change, you feel the system respond to that change, and sometimes fiercely. After a chat, ISIS and her family had to the National Museum of African-American History and Culture. At the exhibit commemorating the Greensboro Four, Royce pauses. Come on guys. This is your great uncle, we could come to the sea.
当你做出改变时，你会感受到系统对这种改变的回应，有时是猛烈的。聊天结束后，伊西斯和她的家人来到了非裔美国人历史文化国家博物馆。在纪念格林斯博罗四人组的展览上，罗伊斯停了下来。来吧，伙计们。这是你们的曾叔公，我们可以来看海。
He gathers his children around him. Yes, that's your great uncle right there. And he says, I had the most wonderful feeling. I had a feeling of liberation restored manhood. I had a natural high and I truly felt almost invincible. Mind you, I was just sitting on a dumb stool and not having asked for service yet. It's Franklin McCain in 2009, that's just before he died. Royce and Jessica are idealists. They're also stubborn people who can come across to critics as rigid and dogmatic. Maybe you've met people like this in your own life, they make it difficult to go about business as usual.
他把孩子们聚集在身边。是的，那就是你们的曾叔公。他说，我有一种最美妙的感觉。我有一种解放的感觉，重获男人的尊严。我有一种天然的兴奋感，我真的觉得自己几乎是不可战胜的。请记住，我当时正坐在一张愚蠢的凳子上，还没有要求服务。这是 2009 年的富兰克林·麦凯恩，就在他去世前不久。罗伊斯和杰西卡是理想主义者。他们也是固执的人，在批评者眼中可能显得死板和教条。也许你在生活中遇到过这样的人，他们让一切照旧变得很困难。
They can make a big deal over seemingly small issues and then stick to their positions with maddening ferocity. But when you think about how a culture revolves, it's because of people like Royce and Jessica, people who wake up one morning and decide they're going to be the change they want to see. This episode of Hidden Brain was produced by Jennifer Schmidt, Raina Cohen, Lucy Perkins and Gabriella Saldevia. It was edited by Tara Boyle. We had original music from Ramteen Arableui.
他们会在看似微小的问题上大做文章，然后以疯狂的凶猛坚守自己的立场。但当你思考文化是如何演变的时，正是因为像罗伊斯和杰西卡这样的人，他们某天早晨醒来，决定成为他们想要看到的改变。这期 Hidden Brain 由詹妮弗·施密特、雷娜·科恩、露西·帕金斯和加布里埃拉·萨尔德维亚制作。塔拉·博伊尔对其进行了剪辑。我们的原创音乐来自拉姆蒂恩·阿拉布鲁伊。
Our team includes René Clar, Parth Shah and Maggie Penman. Our unsung hero today is Camilla Smith. Camilla is a member of the NPR Foundation Board of Trustees and she's been an early and vocal supporter of Hidden Brain. She's a very definition of an unsung hero. Camilla loves to work without drawing attention to herself. She sees far more than she lets on and she's always generous with her encouragement. Every time I meet her, I feel more energized about my work.
我们的团队包括勒内·克拉尔、帕尔特·沙阿和玛吉·彭曼。我们今天的无名英雄是卡米拉·史密斯。卡米拉是 NPR 基金会董事会的成员，她一直是 Hidden Brain 早期且直言不讳的支持者。她完美诠释了无名英雄的定义。卡米拉喜欢默默工作，不吸引对自己的注意。她看到的远比她透露的要多，而且她总是慷慨地给予鼓励。每次见到她，我都对自己的工作感到充满活力。
Thanks, Kimmela. For more hidden brain, please follow us on Facebook, Twitter and Instagram. Next week on the show, we'll explore the science around gender-neutral parenting. We'll look at what the research says about whether boys naturally gravitate to trucks and girls naturally gravitate to dolls. I hope you'll join us. I'm Shankar Vitantam and this is NPR. you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
谢谢你，金梅拉。想了解更多 Hidden Brain 的内容，请在 Facebook、Twitter 和 Instagram 上关注我们。下周的节目中，我们将探讨围绕性别中立育儿的科学。我们将看看研究关于男孩是否天生喜欢卡车、女孩是否天生喜欢洋娃娃的说法。希望你能加入我们。我是香卡·维丹塔姆，这里是 NPR。这个剧集还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。